Hello everyone, how are you? Welcome to
Next Level Commander. This is Jyn and
today we are going to try something
different. We are going to build
together a new Final Fantasy Legend. Oh,
but before we begin, one second cuz I
have to quickly announce the winner of
the previous giveaway from my last
video. 15 cards, 15 years, something
like that. I don't remember. I didn't
really promote or advertise this. I just
hit it at the end of the video and this
individual subscribed and made a comment
and yeah, they won. The winner is Cal
Delet. Cal Delet, thank you. I will
message you privately. And for the rest
of you, please like and subscribe for
future videos and giveaways. But more
importantly, if you have an any opinion,
any thoughts about the content, leave a
comment because a lot of this stuff is
experimental. Like today, the deck
building, I never done this before. I
don't see similar videos on YouTube, so
I wanted to try it. But if it's a video
that you like or dislike or and what you
look forward to in the future, let me
know because as a smaller YouTuber, this
it can get straight to me and can
definitely change the direction I take
in the future. But anyways, moving on.
As you can see, we have Gilgamesh. Now,
this is not not the most popular
commander out of the gate, but I think
it definitely has potential. And I chose
this guy from the new set because I mean
it's not super complicated like a lot of
the new I think overdesigned commanders
or the top down commanders but uh it's
fairly straightforward right focused
with equipments but it's also not the
easiest in terms of difficulty. I would
say this is like medium partly because
the expensive cost and again you're in
model red so your your options are kind
of limited. So yeah, a commander with a
fairly straightforward line of thinking,
but with some hoops we have to jump
through. It's a I think a great deck for
us to try for our first uh build
together. And we're not going to cut or
take any pauses. We're going to try to
do this one take. I don't know if it's
possible, but we'll try. And this will
take maybe around I'm guessing 90
minutes to two hours. Hopefully shorter.
We we'll make it try to make it quick.
Yeah. Um, and also we're not going to be
using any EDHR track related tools. I'm
not saying EDHRE is bad, but it's
actually I mean it's actually excellent,
especially if you don't have too much
time or interest to do the digging and
you're totally fine using EDH to start
and you and then you can play with the
deck and later tune and optimize it as
you play. But not using it, I think, at
least in the beginning, allows us to dig
deeper and to find cards that we
ourselves we want to play and giving us
more room for customization, especially
for an equipment deck where there's
like, you know, maybe a few hundred
equipments. We can pick and choose our
favorites. You know, the difference
won't be like the difference between the
staple equipment, quote unquote, versus
what you choose. There will be a
difference, but it probably won't be
massive, right? You can play with your
own choices and see if it's actually
better or see if you like it more,
right? And I also believe that going
through a process like this once in a
while does help a lot with your deck
building, it makes a huge difference and
it because it prompts us to really think
about every card choice and think about
the synergies, the interactions rather
than just mindlessly adding the most
popular options. And it's a cumulative
process that can help us in the future
if you plan to, you know, keep playing
commander for a while. And at first you
may start slow, but the payoff is worth
it in the in my opinion. So no further
ado, let's take a look at our commander
today,
Gilgamesh. So six mana, 66, pretty
expensive for a commander. When he
enters or attacks, look at the top six
cards of your library. You may put any
number of equipments among them onto the
battlefield. The rest from the bottom
you can, and important here, you can
when you put one or more equipments onto
the battlefield this way, you can equip
one of them, attach one of them to a
samurai you control. I believe attaching
to a samurai here is a bit bit of a I
say red hearing because you probably
won't be playing samurai tribal like
when if you can you're putting it onto
your commander and you're only getting
one equip per turn on average so you're
not going to waste it on another
creature unless unless later I we'll do
a quick samurai search but I doubt we're
going to find something that's very good
in this deck maybe one or two cards from
the new set that I haven't looked at but
for now for now we are going to yeah go
with our whoops what did I do no not
Wait, not a good
start. Okay, there you go. And then
we're going to set it as our
commander. There you
go. How do you I Okay, we have a
commander. And usually I recommend for a
deck like this, the first thing you do
is you go through the core of the deck,
right? You have a core that you pretty
much must have in the deck.
And then you find other cards that may
have synergy with this core. And the
core of this deck is fairly obvious.
It's equipments and more importantly
large equipments because we're cheating
the casting cost and sometimes the equip
cost. So we are using
scryfall. I'm actually not that good at
using scryfall. I use I don't know a lot
of the syntax, but for me basic search
usually does fine as long as my internet
works. There you go. All right. Red. We
want to search red commander identities
because a lot of the equipments are
colorless. Uh equip
wait really. There you go. And we want
the CMC. Let's try mana value higher
than
four. Higher than four.
Right. Well, there's only 20 of
them.
Really? Did I mess up my search? I I
would expect there to be more than 20. I
guess our color is
restrictive, but okay, let's take a
look. I guess there are only 20. Yeah,
off the top of my head, I can't think of
anything that's not in here. So, let's
go. First of all, a tier and priv priv.
Yeah, my apologies. Equip creature. Get
have space power and toughness. Xaxx
will access your total. Yeah. Yeah, it's
huge. Did I? Oh, I hate
this. No. What did I do? Okay.
Automatic. Yeah. I mean, this is huge.
Your commander will be one shot. So, I'm
pretty sure you play it. Argentum armor
plus 6 plus 6 destroy target permanent
six and six to equip. I don't think this
one makes it to be honest. Just because
destroying any destroying one thing is
just
not not that good anymore, is it? And
and then if you don't cheat it in,
you're going to pay a lot. I think we'll
put this on the maybe board, but I doubt
we're going to actually use it. Batter
skull. Batter skull is interesting
because we do want other
creatures and the living weapon because
we only get to equip one one creature or
one equipment at a time, right? So the
other equipments that get dropped, we
want them to do something and living
weapon is one way for them to do that.
And also lifelink is very
important. So I think we try it. I think
we try it. We might have to cut it cuz
we only have maybe 20 I'm guessing 20 to
25 slots for equipments. So we're not
going to play Yeah, we're not going to
play all of them. And this might get
cut. Next one. Dissection tool manifest
dread. So, this one is actually kind of
similar to B skull except it's only plus
two and death touch. Death touch is not
super relevant. We do want lifelink
because in this deck, I mean, chances
are you're not playing a lot of other
creatures and your commander is the one
thing you're doing. So, if your
opponents attack you, you don't have
much defense and you need to race them
with lifelink. But this one, I just
don't think that's enough. Death touch
is not relevant unless you have trample.
And we won't have too much trample. I
think I think our evasion will come from
some a little bit of trample, a little
bit of uh unblockable and some
protection from colors. So, we will see
this one. Flying and haste plus two.
Haste is a huge one cuz it lets us, you
know, cast recommener flip this and get
another trigger immediately. So, I'm
pretty sure this goes in. I can't think
of too many premium haste enablers that
are better than this. I mean, also it's
like a nice living weapon. It's just a
44 dragon on its own, right? What did I
Did I
just
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. We're good.
Really should have practiced this first,
but then we lose the authenticity,
right? This is actually no practice. One
take. Ember cleave. Absolutely. This is
so iconic and so
good. Trample double strike plus one.
Yeah, just everything we want except for
maybe haste is missing. Excalibur. This
is the kind of stuff we want. Huge mana
cost, huge pump. Yeah, we want to get it
done fast because we're not going to
we're not going to win the long game, I
don't think. Double strike, extra com.
Oh, I didn't This is so good. I did not
see this one in the spoilers, but
yeah. Another extra
combat.
Absolutely. Kra
complete. Yeah, I mean batter skull is
iffy because it's just a four for life
thing, but this one is this is one heck
of a creature even if we don't get to
equip it. So, pretty sure we're
including this. I mean, also, why are we
playing equipment decks? We want to play
this stuff, right? This is the reason
we're building equipment deck. Cascade.
No man, death touch
one. None of these abilities are super
relevant. I mean, it's super cool and
epic. If you like this card, play it.
But just doesn't do that
much. And again, if you like the card,
play it. There's no there's no harm in
playing like say if this replaces, let's
say, Battle Skull or or
Excalibur. You will feel a difference,
but it won't be so huge that the joy of
playing your favorite card won't won't
cover.
So, all right. No.
Uh, probably not. Yeah, we just want
lifelink. And we're Nope. We're winning
through commander damage, so we don't
need
this. Makes a dragon for six
mana. Such a cool card, but I think it's
the cost is just way too high. And
nowadays, all these can be probably
reduced by two, maybe.
Yeah. Ro Slayer Ultimate Weapon. What is
this? Whenever your hook attacks,
destroy. Oh, this is just a worse worst.
What's it called? Our gentle armor.
Yeah, this must be from the starter
decks, right? Guess it's just not that
good. All right, that's all of our big
equipments. How many do we have? We have
eight. Eight is not bad. And of course,
we'll need some smaller equipments. So,
I'm guessing we're looking through all
of them. Yeah, let's see how many they
are. If they're over a few hundred,
maybe not.
But we'll see. So less
than
five
380. Okay, this might take a little bit
of time, but but this is again the core
of our deck. So we want to make sure we
play our favorite cards. So baseball
bat, first strike, Dalek,
no artifact control. Look at the top six
cards. So, we don't really want the
equipments in our hands. It's not super
helpful. We'd rather draw a card than
have this ability. And this is pumping
for, you know, usually three or four.
So, not
amazing. Let's see. Nope.
Nope. And the
real don't really need the tokens and
don't really need the counters
either.
Nope. Nope.
Draw two cards just pirate. No assault
suit. Oh, this doesn't gold is the
problem. So your opponents don't even
have to attack. If this golded, this
will be amazing. Does give haste. Ah,
it's tempting. But yeah, your opponents
are likely not going to
attack just because of how aggressive
you are, right? You are possibly the
arch enemy at least for the first five
or six
turns maybe. Avorous amulet. Nope. Nope.
Nope.
Nope. Bass color. Yeah, we're not going
to play equipment just for the lifelink.
Doesn't do
enough. Activated ability. We don't have
any activated. Haste is nice, but we
won't be using this
part. Uh, Bilbo's
ring. Hex proof can be blocked. See,
this is nice
because imagine you're alpha striking an
opponent. You're trying to alpha strike
them and they are able to block, but
then you flip this. Now, they have no
chance to respond. Like, they cannot
point a removal at your commander in
response to this cuz the moment they see
this, your ability is resolving and it
will come down and equip. And now you
have unblockable. And it's possible that
your opponent is just dead. So, this is
nice.
But, oh, this is
tempting. Draw a card. equip
four, but only on your turn. I got hex
move. Maybe board. Maybe
board. Yeah, because the situation I
described is a little bit narrow. It's a
little bit
narrow. It's amazing if it happens, but
uh it's too slow. We don't need the This
is good because it's only five, right?
Two plus three, but it can give plus 6
plus 6 or maybe more. So
definitely Marriott. No, like Oh, wait,
wait, no. Yes, we do want Marriott.
Yeah, cuz sure the copies died, but but
you get say three opponents, you get
four more triggers. Yeah. Yeah, we want
Marriott. Almost skipped it because I I
was thinking thinking legend rule,
but No, sorry, not four more. You get
two more triggers. get two more triggers
because they don't
attack. They just
enter. Is two more triggers worth it? I
think so. I think so. Nope. Nope. Damage
deals. Nope. No. No. No. No. No.
No. On card. On
card. I This gets huge later, but it's
late game only, so probably
not. Haste. Nope.
What's this? Oh, almost missed Buster's
sword. What does it do? Draw a card. You
may cast a spell. So, it's card draw and
you may get a free spell. Doesn't give
you evasion. Just gives plus
three. I don't think we need help
casting equipments from our hands. I I
guess we do cuz I mean if we draw them,
we want to I think this is a maybe board
and it's a cool new card, too. So, I
kind of want to try it even though I
don't think it's the best fit in this
deck cuz we don't need that many
equipments on the board. We just need we
just need, you know, two or three. One
for protection, one for pump, and we are
already two hitting our
opponents. Oh, and one for one for
evasion. Nope, no, no, no,
no. Hex proof. Yeah, we need more
protection. So, absolutely.
Chainsaw. Rev
counter. No, it's too
small. First strike, trample
haste. Now, if this was flying, I would
No, maybe not flying. If this was like
vigilance or flying or lifelink, I would
play it. But as is,
no. Is there equipment that gives flying
vigilant
haste? H. We'll see. I remember there
being one. Cloak of the bat. Flying in
haste. Yeah, I think that's worth it.
Worth a
slot. Yeah, I think it's worth a
slot. Shroud and plus two. Do we want
shroud? I don't think so. I don't think
our commander's ability
targets. Yeah, it doesn't target, but we
won't be able to equip anything else
manually. Like lightning grief. I will
play just because it's zero equip. I can
move it. But this one, yeah, no colossal
hammer plus
10. Uh, for now I want to say no just
because we
are I don't know. Loose is
flying. It's kind of funny though. I
guess maybe board for now. It's kind of
funny. Commander plate protection from
everything except red. Yeah, excuse
me. Ah, see this is similar to the Bilbo
string thing except it locks your
opponent even more even harder just
because the moment they see it from your
ability, they cannot do anything. They
cannot respond and no more spells. They
can they can do abilities but no more
spells. So this is Yeah, maybe we can
just have one of these for the alpha
strike scenario. But the ring
gives gives unblockable and draws you
cards. Do we play the ring or this one?
The ring or this
one? I'm leaning towards the ring even
though it's three and four. Are we a
halfling? We are
not. Oh, maybe we're
both. All right. When you cast your
second spell each turn. Nope.
Crystal slipper. I just want this for
the
flavor. How does it fit? It
fits.
No,
no, I need to go fast. Why am I wasting
time? Okay. Uh, plus one for each
creature you control. If there is no
monarch, become
monarch.
Yeah, dark steel plate.
There's not that much indestructible
even though this is kind of outclassed
by the new I think it's called myithal
coat but this is I think still worth
playing just because it sticks around
it's always there to give value and you
can always pay two mana to protect
something even if it's not your
commander if it's just a random creature
then that creature that creature is
holding the fort so I think this card is
very underrated dark still play yeah I
think we we play it we play
it later if it turns out there's a lot a
lot of other other indestructible
givers then we might cut it but I don't
think I don't think there's too
many what this do craft with
artifact
no wait plus two plus two hex proof for
mono color it cost one less for each
color of the creature so cost three no I
don't think it's worth
No, no, no, no,
no. Plus
fiveish. I think it's worth
it. It's cheap though. So maybe work cuz
the pump is nice.
[Music]
Excell damage. No double strike. We have
double strike, I
think. What is
this?
Nope.
Nope. Nope. Nope. Uh,
blendering in.
Nope. Where's hot soup? I want hot
soup. That touch. Nope. Nope. Okay. I
think we're going fairly quickly. What
time is
it? I actually don't know, but I think
we're going. We're moving along.
Next.
Infect. In fact.
Well, maybe. I don't think we're using
it, but this double strike is way too
expensive. plus four. Yeah, see this is
indestructible. That's really good. But
the equipment itself doesn't have
indestructible. So, it's a little bit
different than dark steel plate. Dark
steel plate will just usually when you
cast it, it will just stick on the board
for the entire game to give you value
over time. Meanwhile, this will get, you
know, will get wiped along with your
commander. Not along with your
commander, but this will protect your
commander, but maybe if someone cast a
board, all the equipments will be gone,
including
hammer. Uh oh, there you go. Wait,
visual. Okay, visions trample
haste. Yeah, I think this can enough
keywords. Nope. Nope. Nope. No. What?
Oh, there's the activated ability that
we can copy, but I don't think we're
doing it. Um, plus comfort.
No. Do we want the Kra set? Ah, first
strike trump haste is not bad.
We'll put it in the maybe board and see
what the other ones do. If the other
ones can do some something similar to
this, I again the cards are not good.
Not amazing, but I mean it's the counter
set. It's so cool. This one definitely
you get an extra commander. One to one
to attack, one to
defend. Yeah, hero's blade. Uh yeah, I
wish this gave haste, but
no kid. No, no, no, no.
Oh,
yeah. It's nice to see
though. Infantry shield. See, this is
cool. But if the I don't think we need
another what 12 tokens attacking. Our
commander should be getting it done. And
meanwhile, if the tokens stayed, I would
play this. But then this would also cost
a lot more. And nope double damage. No
no double strike trample I think is good
enough even if we never use the the
opening hand ability. The lay line
ability. Greaves I think is a yes even
though it's got shroud but it doesn't
stop the equip ability. And if we want
to equip other
things, we can move greaves around to
other creatures that we might we
probably will have. All right. How many
do we have now? Equipments. 20 19
equipments. So, six more at most. We're
not playing more than 25 equipments. I
don't think we need other tools
otherwise this deck will just be so
topheavy. Lizard Blade double strike.
Now, this is some efficient double
strike. I like it. And
also, yeah, I like it because lizard
blades, like in a pinch, lizard blades
can also carry equipments super well.
So, I think that goes in Los
GT. This one definitely lifelink and
trample.
Um,
nope. Nope. Wait, what's this? Oh,
proof.
Nope. Nope.
I throw a cult.
Absolutely.
Millionaire doesn't do
anything. Uh 44. We don't need the
angel. We're going to lifelink it.
That's what we're
doing.
Nikote. Is that the one with No. No.
No. Nope.
No. Well, for each artifact living
weapon. So that Yeah, but this won't be
like a plus five plus five at
most probably. We won't have a huge port
of
equipments. It's probably
not.
No.
No. Plus two plus one haste. Are we a
warrior? We are not a warrior. Okay.
discards your hand.
Nope.
Nope. What does this do? Draw a card to
discard a card. Equip one. Craft with
more creature. I can't craft with
creatures.
Control. It's not Oh, it's not any good.
Like if our commander dies, we can craft
with our commander and then we can turn
other things into our
commander. Just too obsolete. Too too
What's osite? Too convoluted is the
word. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. No. No.
Oh, next 60. We're almost done. Yeah,
we're pretty close to finish. So, could
thy return to the battlefield? This is
like protection with lifelink, but you
need sack outlets. Like, if you have
sack
outlets, you know what? This one might
be decent. I may be
boarded. The reason why I'm really
hesitant now because we still have what,
eight swords waiting for us. Yeah, we're
not really setting a budget restriction
for this one. Later, we can we can find
other alternatives. The swords are good,
but they're not necessary. But if you
have the means, I mean, they're they're
excellent cards. Like, one of the
reasons you play equipment decks is for
the swords, right?
trample life link permanence blue hex
proof we're not going to have too many
removals probably so
indestructible maybe board probably not
crazy triple lifelink is good definitely
good
but this ability is not super relevant
plus one. Okay, maybe maybe this goes in
in the end. Now, let's look at the Cra
set. Indestructible. Indestructible.
It's just a dark steel plate, but more
expensive. Uh yeah, I don't think we're
playing culture,
unfortunately. Because the swords are
coming up. We are We are at S
shortbow. Just kidding.
Um,
Shuko
night. What? Side
quest. How is this? Oh, it's an
equipment in the back. No. Nah, I was
like, how did you make it? This one goes
in for sure. It's a protection spell
that gives
unblockable. Okay, let's see. What else
have we
got?
[Music]
H. Now you can see I'm just trying to
get to the
swords forest you control. We can make
some forests.
No.
Sting
haste on tap. So
vigilance first
strike. Don't think it does
enough. Yeah. No.
Is my standard getting higher as we go?
Like, did I put in some crap early on?
Maybe I did. Maybe this
one. And we'll have to play and see.
First draft. Your first draft cannot be
perfect, but we can try to push it
extremely
close. Um, this can Yeah, this can pump
like a lot. But is it a lot a lot? By a
lot lot I mean like more than 15 because
your commander is a
66. It is not a lot a lot and it only
pumps. So I don't think it's good
enough. Swiffer boots.
Yes. Okay. SW time. Body and mind. Nope.
Feast and famine. Yes. Fire and ice.
Maybe. Maybe.
for Frontier.
Yes. And the the ramp ones are I think
are just good because we got to pay for
that commander tax.
Uh okay. And uh gets a land and he can
blink our
commander. Do we want to blink our
commander considering it probably has
the sword and a bunch of other things
equipped? We blink it for another
trigger. Probably not. This one goes
into maybe board. Guess it's a land
though.
But sword of TRA. Nope. Nope. Light and
shadow. Nope. Ones in future.
Serveville. Nope. Nope. We're not
playing most of the swords, but there
there has to be. I remember there being
Yes. F word in peace is
good. Word of peace is pretty
aggressive. Vigilance trample. First
strike. Vigilance trample. Haste.
I think I will be playing this over the
chariot from
earlier. The cloak. The cloak goes to me
board. Now, this is the keyword, too. I
forgot about this card. Sword of
vengeance. It's
nuts. Wealth and power. Yeah,
definitely. We're not playing a lot of
instant sorceries, but we will have
some. So, but more relevant is the
protection for instance and sorceries.
And also the treasure is nice.
What the uh doesn't untap. No. What?
Vigilance.
No. Ah, yes. Ether
spark. Masamune. What does that do? Must
be blocked. Your dying custard could.
No. That's too specific. That many
treasure tokens.
E. The maybe board because it's really
tempting. is it's a bit wind more but
must must feel good to have it have it
happen. Whenever you attack, you can
double strike, create a thing or see
this card too, draw two is really good
just because our hand will be filled
with equipments. A lot of the large
equipments that we probably won't be
casting and also again double strike is
always good and making. Yeah, I think
this makes it I think it make How many
equipments do we have?
31. We are five over
already. Toro, let's hope we don't see
anything else. That's good. Please. No.
Oh no
doubles. Oh, this one is pretty good.
Crap. This one is pretty good. I think
we maybe board
it. I don't think maybe board is ever
coming out. Like maybe we can play the
game and then if any of this be uh turns
out to be under underwhelming, we will
sub some of these in. I mean just double
strike is so good and also double power.
This stacks with double strike. So in
theory, you can one turn double strike
two mana plus three plus two. You can
double strike and double power and your
opponents are just dead. Well, one of
them is dead if you
trample. It's tempting. We will see. We
will
see. All right, moving
on. Yay. I thought we're finished.
Please. Ah, this is so good. Is it? It
is. Crap.
fly. Oh, we are finished. Okay. 32. I
think we're cutting six. Yeah. Six
artifacts or six equipments. Flying
haste, though. Haste is so
good. Is it? Yeah, it's so
good. All right, let's be very critical.
Yes. Yes. Absolutely.
Yes. Yes.
Yes. Think so. I think so.
Yep. This will pump for maybe six or
seven and it's only five mana, right?
This pumps more than any other big pump
that we've seen that's like around this
mana cost,
right? Do we play this? It's can't be
blocked and shroud. Your opponents
basically have to like react to this in
a turn or they're dead. So I think it's
very
good again like the again like Bilbo's
ring right you flip it boom it's going
through wolf empower is it that
good mean put that in the maybe
board because I don't know how many
instances source we we will have some
definitely
but probably not that many and not that
many we want to cast our main face that
that's also important
So, uh,
continue. One down, five to
go. These cars. I think batter has to
go. We have enough
lifelink. Cloak. Yeah. Doesn't do that
much. Uh. How many are we at? No, it's
only nine. Okay, so we need to cut three
more. Okay, let's do it. Let's do it. We
can do
it. Double strike is just so good. And
also extra combat. The pump. They keep
printing these amazing equipments. You
know what, Warren? Uh from white though.
Protection from white.
Sufah hoots silver shout
costume. Maybe the plate can make room
for network commander plate protection
from what the protection is.
Awesome. Maybe this doesn't do enough.
Yeah.
One or can we be a bit greedier and sit
at 27 equipments?
I think 20 honestly I think 25 is
already a lot. So yeah, let's let's cut
a few just
to double strike. We have a lot of
double
strike. Not we have a
lot. You know
what? This might be a mistake. But
again, if we find that we are short on
protection, we can come back. So now
that we have the equipment package set,
we have to take a look at so once we
have the core of the deck, we have to
take a look at what synergizes with our
core, right? And like I was saying
earlier, we have a lot of we might have
a lot of equipment stuck in our hands.
So I'm pretty sure we need some discard
and draw spells. That's what we need.
And off the top of my head, there is
definitely scroll rack. That's a staple
in these decks.
Skorak. But aside from that, we're going
to do some research. I think Skorak is
famous enough for people to know about
it. But the other cards, I think there's
at least, you know, 10 really good
discard and draw effects. We'll have to
see if which ones are the best. So,
discard
draw and
pipeline. I think we don't restrict
typeline, do we?
We'll see.
Red.
Go. How many are there? 200. Not too
bad. Let's go.
Go. Yeah. I don't think we're playing.
What does this do? Discard. Card. Draw a
card. Unre false
cost. No, not
quite. Do we play
looters? I don't think so. Because the
looters themselves, they cost one card.
So, I was thinking more those what's it
called? The where you have to discard a
card and draw two and you get two
treasures. There's like three of
them. Yes, but Zar of back. No, not
quite. There you go. Big score. These
are good. Bit of
reunion. I think this one is good. Yeah,
because again, haste is just huge in
this deck.
Uh,
no. Discard any number. Draw any number
if you descend it this turn. So, it's
not going to
flip. But
again, no, I'll be discarding like
two. So, basically, I'm discarding two,
draw
three. This one.
Nope. Cavalier is interesting.
discard any number. Draw that many cards
and it gives haste, but it cost a fair
bit of mana. So, probably not. Cathar
reunion. Is this still
good? Discard two draw three is still
good. Might be might
be
chra.
Nope. Nope.
Nope. The ready. Discard two cards. Draw
that many cards. Sacrifice an artifact.
You can This guy can ch like loop
equipments. I don't think there's too
many equipments that are super worth
reanimating. This card. Oh, sacrifice an
artifact. Raw two cards.
This might be good just because we can
have some redundant equipments on the
field. Yeah, it's flexible. It's
flexible. That's what I
like. Faithless
looting
stable. Sure. Supposed to be good.
think we have enough now. Although we
haven't gotten to the
other the other treasure creating
instinct yet. So we will look for
that. Yeah. None of these are super
good. What does this
do? When evasion of ex No.
No. Yes.
No. Oh, this is good. Key to the city is
good. Yeah.
Unblockable. Cause
alike. Probably
not. Discard card drop. This is like a
big faithless
looting. I don't know how to evaluate
these. I think
put this in the maybe
board. Okay, I think we're on the last
page. Almost last page. Second last
page. Because you control it deals
damage, go to power discard draw from
cards. It's actually not bad. I mean, I
didn't mean to look for this,
but do we give protection from red a
lot? So, we have shroud and protection
from red sometimes,
but not not a lot. And if we can just
boom the
board. Yeah, we do need some board
wipes. I think this is good along with
Tundra's ignition. But this is better I
think just because it's four mana and
then you can also refill your hand kind
of this one four mana but it's a sorcery
why just strictly worse no feels bad we
want the good
one where's the good
one before I don't think we're going to
discard drop.
No
speed. Speed. No.
unexpected windfall is the one we're
looking for. Trading post sack equipment
draw a card sack
creep. Discard a card. Gain four life.
Don't think this does enough. Yeah.
Wait, what's the yay do?
No,
no. Wheel of Fortune.
No. No. No. No. No. No. Okay, that's it.
So, now we are sitting at 35 cards.
And at this
point, we want we have a strategy. Yeah,
we have pretty clear strategy. So, we
want to play a few more cards that can
enable to make sure our strategy works.
And in this case, we want some finishers
and some protection spells. Yes. To make
sure our commander can stick because
this we have plan A and no other plan
basically. So protection spells the few
that we know. So for for mono red, the
best we can do
is readites like deflecting
swap. Put that in
first. What? Oh, sorry. Right. Where?
Where? Okay. So, all right. So, what are
we going to search? I think we have to
search change
target. And then we have to make it red
because there's no color. Oh, there is
colorless. There's a colorless one, I
think. So, well, but that one is
protection. So, we're going to have to
do this first. Okay. Change target.
What? Oh, yeah. Bend. Bend. Absolutely.
What's with these
artifacts? Now, this one
costs three mana to do, so it's a bit
expensive. We'll see if we have better
options. I'm sure we do. Do we? What?
Really? This one's good. Change target
and
evasion. Is that
it? I think four protection spells is a
bit low. I included I included uh this
but I don't want to pay three mana for
that
protection but I guess the equipments
also help protect so we don't need need
that many and also there's the colorless
one let's take a look
colorless and it's I think it's
protect and I think we have to do
instance or source foods because
otherwise we'll get the equipments
again let's
See, there we go. Eldrich immunity. Why
is Oh, yeah. This is a land. That's why
this is
colorless. Yeah, I think this is
good. It will make our red equipments
fall off. But we don't have too many of
those. And there's one more card I
remember off the top of my head. It's
called H It's called What? It's called
It says if your commander or if a
creature has seven or more power, this
spell is free. I know you're shouting at
me, but this is not a stream. Ah, not of
this world. Not of this
world. There you
go. Yeah, counter. Oh, counter target
ability. Yeah, I think this is fine. You
can even counter like Amaz. It's really
cool. All right, so we got draw, we got
protection. Now we're at 40 cards. We
will need some finishers. Big finishers.
And how to finish the game? Extra
combat.
Yeah, when your opponents think they
have two turns left, they have zero.
That's how we finish in red. Like, if
your opponents can see you killing them,
you're not killing them. You just don't
have the resources to to deal with other
colors. They can remove, they can board
wipe, they can bounce, right? You have
to kind of catch them by surprise. And
the best way to do it is extra
combat source. I think we limited to
instant sorcery
because there's not that many creatures
that Yeah, I think we have plenty of
instance or sorceries that can give us
the extra combat. What? Oh, sorry.
Partial type
match. I forgot to put the keyword.
Additional
combats. Yeah, this is the best one.
Full throttle, two combats, six
mana, exile, two red
grenel, free running untap that attack.
There's an additional
combat cost three mana if your connect
if your commander connects. I think it's
fine. We will see if we have too many.
We want maybe four or five of these. We
don't want too many cuz the window to
use these is not all it doesn't happen
all the time. You have to have it
everything set up. Uh, this one cost
one, two, three, four. Four mana to to
do extra combat, but also can pump. This
we don't need. And we get one treasure,
maybe two. So, this is not
great. We will see. We will see. We
might come back. Savage beating is
expensive, but it's ridiculous because
you get double strike and extra combat
on one card. So, you can kill easily
kill two opponents with this. So, I
think yeah, at seven mana is fine. And
it's also five mana if you just want one
of the modes. Seize the day. Absolutely.
When you have Voltron, this is Okay,
that's it. How many do we put in? We put
in one, two, three, four. Four. One
more. Okay, let's do one more. All
right, now we are at 45 cards. And we
will definitely need a lot of ramp for
this deck because our commander is so
expensive. Okay, mans. We want them to
be four C. Uh let's just
reset. How do you
reset doesn't? Okay, fine. I willclick
all these. Oh, this is this is fine. Red
and um
add and has to be artifact and not a
creature. I don't think we want creature
ramp. And we want it to be four CMC or
lower less than or equal to four.
Uh okay. Okay. Uh we have 253. But in
this case, I think most of them we know
like we're not going to play with the
bottle heads probably. Although this one
gives haste, but three mana to give
haste. No. Yeah. So I think we know
mostly what we're playing. We're going
to play probably 10 or so mana rocks.
It's a bit high the number, but our
commander kind of recoups the lo the
loss of card
advantage. So hopefully it will be fine.
We won't be out of
gas. Yeah. Okay. So, we'll go fast
here. And I just remembered something. I
just remembered something because there
is a rock kind of that works really well
with this deck. It's the one that gives
artifacts. No, gives
spells. What's it called?
Not affinity. The one for spells for for
artifacts. It's three mana. I'm doing
this now because I'll forget later. So,
I will add it now. It's called not
affinity, not
inspire. It says non
artifact spouse. I think this should get
us there.
What? What? What
is pretty sure it says not? Oh, there
you go. Non artifact spells you have you
cast have impro improvise. Yes. And what
this does is this itself is a mana rock
that helps us that helps us cast our
commander. But it makes every artifact
on board or equipment on board able to
tap to help cast our commander because
chances are there are more creature
wipes than artifact wipes. So your
opponents will be able to deal with this
but possibly leave a board of equipments
around and with this we can basically
bypass the commander attacks and more.
So I think again this is just a three
mana rock right for the purpose of this
deck. So, I'm pretty sure we're doing
this. And for the rest of them, we are
going to And this is kind of tech that
you probably won't think of. Like, it's
impossible to search for something like
this, but as you play or just from uh
experience from the past, you will find
cards like these that are just ah
they're so sweet to to
use. Yeah. But I'm sure I'm missing a
bunch of these, but these are the only
ones I can think of right now. But it's
okay to start off a little bit generic
and then we can slowly make our decks
more and more synergistic. Blitz Ball.
Blitz Ball. I like this a lot. I'll play
I'll play
it just
because it's a draw spell. Like late
game, you can draw with it, right? So,
this will help you power out the
commander and then right immediately
after your commander hits, you can just
cash it in for two cards. So, it's
excellent. All right. No, no, no. I
promise. Okay. Let's go fast now. No
more No more uh curve balls. Everything
straightforward. Nope.
Yes, this one. This one. Yeah, this one
is good because it gives you another
trigger of the commander. All right. You
can just three
mana. Yeah, this is good. Drink
stealing. Probably not. Let's We have
two now. Two. Three. Technically three.
Okay. More. More. More.
We don't want mana double works because
we don't have to use for big
mana stone maybe because our commander
is six mana so I don't think we need too
many too many two mana ones I think
three four mana is fine especially three
uh but then turn two turn
three because if we turn three mana rock
turn four mana rock then we just
accelerated our commander by one turn
but if we can get a turn two mana rock
consistently we accelerated by two turns
so I was wrong we do turn two yes we
want some turn two okay keep looking
keep
looking what is this player die
no monolith
It's so
good, but it's so expensive. What's our
budget at? 430. So, it's kind of
reasonable. If we put this in, the deck
becomes Yeah, I don't think we're going
to stretch our budget like that. Where
are you? I cut
you. There you go. It's also a game
changer.
Um, is this good? You can cash it in
later for two cards. We do kind of want
the mana though, ideally. So, four mana
at two. No, four mana. I honestly I'm
regretting searching for four cuz we
don't want four drop man rocks cuz four
drop man rocks, it only accelerates your
commander by one turn
anyways. So, yeah, they don't do that
much. So, I
think we're not going to play for drops.
Two and three is the the way to
go. Not bobblehead
though. Oh, Joe Lotus is the kind of
enabler this tech needs. But
but gold survival.
No. No.
No, man. Vault again is good, but it's
not worth the the cost. Mind stone.
Absolutely. This new these new arts the
new hearts are really distracting. I
feel like this looks like just a generic
uncommon here. It looks like any other
almost skipped it. Model of unity
forbears. I thought there'd be
more. Pre-triarch
seal. What does this do?
Nope. Nope.
Nope. This one I like. This one I like
because it gives your commander flash
and which make helps it dodge all the
sorcery speed removals. So you can flash
in your commander at the end of your
previous opponent's turn and then attack
immediately. So I want to play
this.
What? It's a new card. Okay,
cool. Cool, cool,
cool. I think this one's good enough.
Yeah, Sky
Clearing. Yay. Again, I almost skipped
it just
because unblockable. Yeah, I think
that's good.
And there's one I'm waiting for. It's
one that the one that turns into an
equipment. That one I think is super
good, but I'm not seeing
it. Theatic
compass. I really like this card, but
maybe not here. Oh, there you go. Iron
Craig. So, your legendary Yeah. It
powers out your commander and then
immediately just turns into an equipment
that attaches to it.
And see, note the the quotation marks
end here. So your commander doesn't lose
the abilities. This this got me confused
for a while. This loses all other
abilities. Yeah. So your it doesn't hurt
your commander. It's just plus three
plus three. And it's free to equip,
right? Oh, no, no, no. It's not free to
equip. But yeah, it's still it's still
pretty good. And it's a two mana mana
rock. It's Yeah, there's not many of
those. We will never have maximum hand
sights.
No treasure map. No. No. No. How many
are we at? 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10. I think we have enough.
Yeah. 10 to 11. Uh, how many cards do we
have
here? 56. We are pretty close. I think
now we just need some generic good
stuff. Generic monor red good stuff. Now
we are not using Rex. So, we're just
going to have to do it off the top of
our heads. And again, the good stuff are
fairly easy to come up with, I'd say,
right? I mean, like we need removal,
chaos
work,
blasphtorm. Also, these damage based
wipes can't be one-sided because of how
big our commanders are. And being uh
starr Yeah, instant speed is huge and
also cycling is nice
sometimes. Should I put
in You know what? I'll do it. thematic
compass. I'll show it to you. So, I will
use card
search just because again we play a lot
of ramp, but if we miss land drops, it's
like you're paying three mana for a rock
and then you miss a land drop. You might
as well just activate the compass and
eventually it ramps you again, turns
into a land with ma fifth ability, which
is super useful in this
deck. Yeah. So, I think we put it in.
This is not a land slot. Oh, what? We're
at 60 cards. We need I think 37 lands in
this deck is
enough. How are we doing? What? What's
with air? Oh, not legal. Okay. Um, yeah,
I think we could use a chest as well
here. It's not too expensive now, is it?
How much is it? What? What's
happening? Yes. Oh, sorry.
There you
go. Now, there you go. We're at Yeah,
we're pushing
$500, but again, when you're doing
monocolor with equipments, it's Yeah,
it's not the most budget friendly route
to
take. Two more cards. We do need more
removals. I can't remember, but but I
think we're just Oh, I remembered the
the counter spell to bolts trickery cuz
that's like a protection spell. So let's
replay that and then two more removals
and then we are done. What's happening?
Why is just because I searched for
compass? Why are you doing this to me?
Okay,
trickery. There you go. I have no idea
what's happening here.
Boom. And then I remember there being
red removals that either shuffle or
destroy. Or do we want ah do we want
some
colorless? You know what? I think this
deck needs an
Ugan. Is it Ugan? Ujin. Ugan. Yeah, just
cuz Ugan like if you if you spend a lot
of money on one card, I think it's Ugan.
Even the swords are not necessary. And
what are the big money cards in this
deck? 49 22. So nothing huge, right?
It's just they add up a little bit. What
was expensive here? Oh, yeah. the
swords. I think Ugan is what you scourge
for. I'm not sure how much it is right
now, but just because there's so much
colorless, all your opponents are
cutless except for your commander who's
six mana and you need board wipes. You
need board. You can't just play without
removals and board wipes. So, I
think don't give me
that spirit dragon. How much is it? 20.
Okay, not too bad. Not too bad.
$22. Are we done?
We are done. Later you might have to
adjust the deck. Maybe cut a few
equipments for more interaction perhaps,
but for now we want to try this. I think
25 is a good ratio because any lower you
have a decent chance of whiffing. Yeah,
we want ideally we want to put one or
two equipments down every attack, right?
So this is fine. Now we're on to the
lands. How do we search for lands?
I think we just go through it really
quickly. Lands commander.
Boom. Astergo. This is really good. It's
like a graveyard hate plus recursion.
Although we don't have many key
artifacts to recur, it's still still
fine, I think. Yeah, the graveyard hate
is super relevant. And we don't need
that much color, to be honest, because
we just need two red. And what else do
we need? Maybe one more red to protect
later. Yeah, we're fine. Let's go fast.
How many lands do we have to choose
from? Yeah, 400. Okay, not as bad as I
thought. Ancient tomb. I really want to
play this ancient tomb,
but yeah, is actually pretty good in
this deck, but we'll we'll we'll save it
for now. Haste. Do we want to play the
speed trio, the three speed lens? Cuz
haste is really
good. I'll maybe board them. This this
may this one they might actually come
out of the maybe board, but I have to
see what all three of them do. Okay, go
go go go go fast. Oh, haste. Almost
missed
it. Go, go, go.
What? Discard a card. See, this is a
loot, which is also decent. Why we need
to play three? Because we're doing
Oh, you know what? Never mind. because
we are not going to be hitting our
opponents that much. Like we'll be
hitting them, but each hit will be like
half of the commander damage meter.
So, every hit will be
difficult. The chance of us playing the
land and then enabling speed going to
two, three, four, I don't think is super
high. So, never mind. I don't think we
play the speed
lands,
but we can keep looking.
Blink Moth we don't need but I think we
do play Ink Moth just as a backup backup
win condition. Do we want this draw only
for power greater? No, it's only usable
late. And if our commander is on the
board, we have better use for the mana.
Probably. So probably
not. We don't have anything that's if we
have an oblivious stone here, maybe. But
we don't have anything that's super
important to recur. So,
no plus one. Exalted.
Nah, we don't need the plus
ones. Hide away. Nope. Command beacon.
Yes. Our commander is going to get
killed. No. This This land is just not
very good, I
think.
Village. Um.
No, no, no, no. What is this? Nonhuman.
This is a human.
Ah, destroy land. We do need to blow up
Miths. So, we will
see. Is this like another command beacon
almost? Not really.
Paste.
Yes. Discard a
card. This is good. Is this
expensive? I'm not sure. We'll see.
538. Oh, it's a bit expensive, but this
is really good
because Yeah, because you have a lot of
artifacts. Usually three or four, right?
Then you can discard a card and then you
can because you don't have to get an
artifact. You can get anything. Yeah, I
think this is worth
playing.
But everyone gets to do it though, so
no.
Um, oh,
absolutely. Sure, why not? Again, we
don't care too much about them being
colorless. Do we want to play this to
work with
Ugan? No. So, we don't have ways to
tutor either either of
these. Scollet. Do we need a
psychic?
We don't. I don't think so. Home word
path. No, I don't think so. What is
this? Nope. Yeah, there you go. We need
Inkmoth as our backup. This is like my
one backup condition to strap two
equipments onto Inkmoth and boom and
boom people for 10 infect.
All right. Inventor's fair. Search for
an artifact. Don't again. I don't
think G's
life. Oh, sorry. I don't know why I keep
looking at the maybe board, but
um yeah, the the meat is
here. Yeah, I should be looking at
these. But no, there's nothing too
important we should we should be looking
for. Maybe like evasion when we need it.
Yeah, maybe.
We'll
see. Yeah, I'm starting to think as long
as have a has a little bit of value, we
can just play the lens, the colorless
lens, cuz we don't care so much about
colors. Sack a creature. This can bring
our commander back for for eight mana.
No, this
is
No, this one's decent. This one's
decent. Let's store
mana. Yeah. Moaning wall.
No
workshop. Mary landscape is good. Do we
want a mutal?
can turn into a samurai,
but it can help
us stop edict effects or like you know
those flashback marers. So, we'll see.
Maybe. Oh, we are so close. How long has
I want to know what time it is. We're at
just above one hour. Okay, this is Yeah,
it's not
bad. This sure and these MDFCs are just
especially the ones that you can pay
life to play. They're you play them very
little very little opportunity cost.
Plaza heroes. This is good. Yeah, this
is a production
spell. Oh, where's that land? That gives
a commander
lifelink. It's called Okay, witches
clinic coming up. Coming up. We don't
need hand sides. Nope. What is this?
Lizard. Nope. Unblockable.
Sure. Hate.
Yes. Sure. Again. Pay three life. Place
some
intercapped. We can afford that life. No
problems.
This is
good. Let's get some blockers or sack
sack foders to the edict effects. Spine
rock.
No, probably
not. I mean, we're just going to get an
equipment and then cheat it in on our
main face. It's not that good. Strip
line. Yes. Do you need at least one?
Maybe even one more like a
wasteland sunken
citadel. Ah, this card this card is
super
good. Yeah, cuz it also protects your
commander and also lets you ramp. If you
just pay four mana, you can put it into
play. Like you can cast your commander
on your main face, do whatever trigger
and then protect it. If you if you're
not in a under too much pressure, you
can just phase it out and the next turn
he will come in and you can
attack, right? Or you can hold if you
can hold four mana. It's just a
protection spell from from everything.
So I think we play it. Even though this
card, how much is it? It's a bit ah
Okay, this card good. Five or more
lands. Maybe not bit
risky. Where's our clinic?
Where is our What's coming up? Oh, the
tower. No, no, no. I cannot play this.
We are a Volron deck with
equipments. Or is a saga searches for
Sori? That's it. No.
There you go. This is one that we can
play. Don't think we play Valut. We We
don't I don't think we have too many
mountains. How many lands do we have
now? We
have 18 lands. 21
lands. Yeah, getting getting five other
mountains from from my experience
doesn't doesn't really happen even in
monocolor.
So, I'll skip it for now.
War room.
Yes. Wasteland.
Yes. Winding cannons. I like a lot. Like
you can again the same reason is the
flash is good. Your commander is so big
that you drop it. If it doesn't attack
immediately then your opponents will
just be staring at it as like they have
an entire turn to remove it. It's a big
dumb thing that's sitting there possibly
with no protection. So, I think we play
it. Oh, there you go. There's the
clinic. And I think this rounds up.
Yeah. Our non-basic lands. And we come
to the most challenging part of the
deck, which is picking which mountain
art to use. We need
uh 13, I think. 13 more lands. 12 more
lands. 12 more.
Okay. Car search. Go. Oh, go
away. I'm so sick of you. But how do you
I don't understand why this keeps coming
up. Why? Oh, because Okay.
Mountain. Nope.
There. Well, we can't choose the
mountain. Yes, we can. Yes, we can. Set
comp. No. No. No.
You know what? Oh, there you go. There
you go. I was just about to give up
Final Fantasy. This one. Does
Gilgamesh fit this kind of It's kind of
Japanese samurai kind of.
Nope. There has to be a samurai
mountain,
right? Gilgamesh's fort here. No. Let's
go to Kamagawa then because we have the
samurai aesthetic. Show
more. Okay, we will settle. I'm sorry I
I dropped the ball, but we will settle
for now. Not this. Not for
this. Yeah, sure. Mountain samurai
works. 12. Is it 12?
Yes.
Go.
Go. What's happening?
I think we did it. 100 cards $800, but
we can cut it down to 500 if you don't.
There's a few cards that are like $30,
$40. I think you can cut them painfully,
but it's cutable. And here we go. This
is the Gilgamesh deck that we made in an
hour and 20 minutes
approximately. And we'll be right back.
Welcome back. And here's what our deck
looks like.
Honestly, I don't really understand how
architect organizes these cars. I have
to do it manually if I really want them
to be neat because I tried to group by
categories, but it doesn't make much
sense. So, I guess we'll do it by type,
which makes it clear. And again, I'll
talk a little bit about the budget
because we'll sort by price. Yeah,
again, the deck is sitting at $800 for I
believe the cheapest versions, but this
is a bit inflated because of just a few
cards. Uh, for example, Deflecting Swat
at 60. Oh, this is expensive. Yeah,
Valut Awakening. It's a good card, but I
think it's quite good in this deck, but
again, it's not nothing that we cannot
cut. And looking down here, Commander
Plate is definitely not necessary. You
can replace this with any protection or
just any equipment really. We we've got
enough protection, I'd say. And down
here, Jessica's Will again is really
good. $22.
But I mean, most of the time we'll be
playing this as a ritual. So you can
play a parotic ritual instead of this
and you will probably do okay. Or the
other card called Iron Craig Feat, the
one that costs four mana and adds seven
mana to your
pool. I think we'll do similar things.
And I didn't know this card was so
expensive at $14, right? $14. So it's
cutable.
So, the only card I again, like I was
saying, I really want to spurge for this
deck would be Ugan because it's in this
deck. It's actually so one-sided and
Ugan is just amazing for any deck that
doesn't have access to good board
wipes.
Yeah. Although, even if we cut a lot of
the expensive cards, it will be
difficult for us to drop this down to
below 500 just because if you look at a
lot of the equipments, people love
equipments and they're not cheap.
They're the average price is kind of,
you know,5 to105 each and you kind of
have to play them because they're the
coolest
equipments. Yeah. So to build such a
deck, you have to be prepared for it to
be kind of at least a mid-budget
deck. But yeah, that is uh that's the
budget part. And now we I guess we can
goldfish it a little bit. Although I
have to warn you, goldfishing is very
misleading just because you can do it to
kind of get a feel of how the mana works
in the early turns or whether Gilgamesh
is going to whiff a lot. But first of
all, because commander, there's so much
variance that you can't really collect
any meaningful data unless you do it,
you know, 100 200 times. A lot of this
is very subjective. And also, time goes
by fast when you're goldfishing. You're
like, "Oh, this is only turn four. I
have my commander." But actually, four
turns is a long time in commander,
right? And by turn four, a lot can
happen, especially when it's powered by
powered by soul ring or multiple soul
rings. So, we'll see. We'll see. I mean,
are you already here? Might as well. Ah.
Uh, we don't want this. Oh, we have we
have three landmark. I think it's fine.
I think it's fine. We just need one more
red source. That shouldn't be a problem,
right? Right. Never punished. Never
punished. Okay, draw. There you go.
There's the red source assuming someone
is playing red at your table, which is
pretty safe, I'd say. Four players,
four, three opponents. Land draw. That's
a good land to draw. But we're going to
power
stone and the commander here. And next
turn, we have our commander. Although
ideally, we don't want to use the talent
gates to drop our commander, but we will
see. Draw. We're using the talent gates.
So, I guess we face out a key creature
on opponent's side and then yeah,
Gilgamesh time. See what we get. Pop
six. Let's get a haste. Double strike
trample. That's a haste,
please. Okay, this is super dangerous
because, you know, your opponent's
seeing this, they probably have to
remove it. And we do not have protection
mana up. So it would have been really
nice if we could drop Gilgamesh and then
Talon case, but I think at this point
it's safe to assume that Gilgamesh is
dying. Yeah, I wouldn't. So yeah,
unfortunately Gilgamesh is dying. But
goldfishing past this point is kind of
pointless because we don't really know
what would happen. But
yeah, and Fore Vault is actually really
good here cuz um you can Wait, did I
just miss this? Yeah, I did. Gilgamesh
is not dying because we protect
it. It's so random sometimes. Yeah. Was
that in my head? That was Yes. Yes.
Okay. Yeah. Cuz Gilgamesh gets plus one
and this is free. All right. We We win.
Uh let's attack. Do we attack? Yeah.
Let's attack and see what
happens.
Boom. Uh do we get Yeah, one more. Yeah,
why not? Hex proof. Oh, did we go
greedy? We do have another protection
spell.
Honestly, I think we go
greedy. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Let's Let's be
greedy. So, yeah. That's what it looks
like. You need to kind
of Sometimes you have to be greedy just
because you're not going to win super
late into the game. So, you have to kind
of get some damage through early and
accumulate some advantage. And blade
themselves. I mean, if we get another
trigger, let's see. Uh, we make we get
three triggers total, right? Top
six. Not great, but six
more. Yeah. Calra. Calra. And then six
more. I got nothing. Yeah, but both of
these are in play, right? So, you can
just equip later. Yeah, this is what a
typical start looks like. I think this
is a fairly average start. Let's try one
more just to see. Um, D two lands. It's
not enough mulligan. Is this enough
lands? But no, I think we go to six
because again this deck mulligan's
really well. You can just, you know, put
the equipments away, right? You don't
have to keep the equipments in your
hand. So, let's mulligan down to five.
Six. Six. Six. Six. S6.66 with a rock.
No, go to five.
Yay. That's such a good hand though. I
want to keep all these. But we'll put
away we'll put away a three rock and a
two
rock. Like this. Like this. Sure. Yeah,
that's fine. Keep
draw. Draw. Play a rock.
Draw. Don't think we'll be able to flash
in Gilgamesh. So, just commander sphere
is fine. Then draw. Time for Gilgamesh.
This is turn four. Gilgamesh. Haste,
please. Indestructible is nice, too, but
haste.
Maybe we don't have enough haste. So, at
least it's protected for our turn.
Hopefully, then uh draw. Oh, see this is
a great turn. If Gilgamesh lived, right,
we
attack.
Holy. So, we just go greedy. I think you
have to go for it. Or when you have the
chance to win, you have to go for it.
playing conservatively is
uh but then but then because you have
this right so it's possible that you
know when you're attacking one opponent
two other opponents are holding removal
and
just
waiting yeah waiting for the chance to
to use it later on but now if I drop
this they don't have a chance anymore if
they have a spot removal and then I get
two more
triggers and We can hope that we get
some something explosive. We're not
taking this because this prevents us
from targeting. So yeah, I think that's
it. And then uh yeah, we're going to
seize the day. So that's four
mana. Another attack. One, two, three,
four, five, six. I think the sword is
fine. Spear is also
good. Sword or spear? Maybe we can use
the spear to loot a little bit. Yeah,
let's take the spear because we get one
more combat. And also sword prevents uh
sees the day. Yeah, that new one. All
according to plan.
Okay. And yeah, sees the day again. I
don't know why I'm tapping, but sees the
day. Six
more. Ah, this would have been nice last
turn or last combat, but it's still
pretty good.
at this point. Maybe commander plate.
No, still this. And then hopefully next
turn we can. Oh, and also we get to
trigger this. We get to discard two
cards and draw two cards. Yeah. And then
we get a production spell, right?
Almost. Oh, we did. We did. Okay.
Although although this is not super
irrelevant now because our opponents are
probably not targeting Gilgamesh,
although they they can target our
equipment, so it's not bad.
All right, let's do just one more. Just
one more. Gold fishing is honestly kind
of addicting. Yeah, this is a good hand.
Good hand. We have two red sources and
uh not the best, but pretty good. Draw.
Land. Draw. Land.
Draw. Commander
Sphere. Draw for a M of
Moria. Do we big score? I think we big
score. Yeah, we big score the end of
turn. So, we discard a card. Discard
Kdra. We're not casting it anytime
soon. Probably not. Yeah. And draw two
and get two gold tokens. So, then what
we're doing is draw for
turn. Didn't get a land, but we have
gold. So, we tap tap t top t top t top
top. Five six. We have one gold left.
Oh, that's a bit awkward. Why we didn't
get a land? I think we use both gold so
we can you we can keep Aldrich immunity
for
protection. Uh yes, that is the correct
play. So we use both her gold and
commander. Yay. Six. One, two, three,
four, five, six. Excellent. Yeah, it's
not bad. Not bad. Not bad.
So yeah, then I don't think this is we
would be using this cuz we have
protection anyways. So let's say we
untap
draw land.
Beautiful.
Um yeah, we attack. See what happens.
Two, three, four, five, six. This is
excellent cuz we are doing
uh yeah we are doing what how much
damage nine damage right nine damage
easily and so ether spark's getting nine
counters and we can make lots of mana
play a bunch of these get one more
Gilgamish trigger destroy
everything and hold up counter spell
because n mana is a lot of
mana h good start okay So, this is the
Gilgamesh deck. Although, I kind of just
thought of this. I remember I promised
early in the game or early in the video
that we are going to look at some
samurai. So, just to make sure we don't
miss any secret crazy good
samurai. Let's take a look. I I I
remember maybe seeing a mono red one in
the new set, but I can't remember. Just
take a look. Boom. Boom. Do it.
Um, this one is not bad. Gives
haste. Aside from that, yeah, aside from
that, there's not too much, I don't
think. Was there a samurai in the new
set? No, maybe not. All right, that is
it for our This is our Gilgamesh video.
And again, this is aimed to show you how
I build a deck from zero, from scratch.
Just, you know, have some ideas and grab
onto the idea and try to make something
happen. Why is there an
ad? Thank you for watching. Thank you
for watching. And please remember to
subscribe. And this is something again
very different. Please let me know if
this is the kind of video you like
because it's a bit longer. It's a bit
slower the tempo. There's no tempo. I
just speak, no script.
And honestly, if you have insomnia, this
this kind of video might be helpful. But
yeah, thank you. See you soon.